my case is that David Cameron has
presided over the biggest loss of
influence for our country in the
generation we launched our English
manifesto so beyond our main manifesto
English voters we believe deserved one
document clarifying and black and white
what they can expect something like this
the problem is many issues are
characterized as English on the issues
when they're anything but they're become
an expert they'll see anything and do
anything not to make the country theatre
but to cling on to paya I wasn't
expecting to be talking tampons with you
miss from know that I'm really but
select like how it we're a broadly based
politic we can remove the 80 from
sanitary products but of course we're
not allowed to do that because the
European Union point support really sort
wrote by though a government on a life
support machine day by day but alex
salmond or Nigel Farage constantly
threatening switch it off or are we paid
and everything are we are we legal
illegal good good good good good good
all right